[Musica]
[Applauso]
in questi anni molte volte mi sono
domandato se la cosa che abbiamo creato
sarebbe potuta nascere da altre parti in
altre città in altri luoghi posti come
new york londra berlino ma mi sono anche
risposto che le idee a volte le idee più
fragili più piccole hanno bisogno di
territori complici cioè di spazi che in
qualche modo sappiano perdonare le
incertezze che non pretendano 1
immediato splendente successo e in
qualche modo torino è un po così e anche
un posto che ha un costo della vita
compatibile con la vita e non sempre
nelle nostre città succede anzi spesso
non succede se pensiamo per esempio che
non voglio dire che milano sia un cesso
è tutt'altro anzi però in questo momento
è particolarmente splendente però con
quello con cui a torino si prende un
appartamento magari da condividere con
qualche amico a milano in realtà davvero
si prende solamente un piccolo spazio se
non proprio un gabinetto e questo forse
è una delle ragioni per cui torino è
diventata un po un luogo per
universitari per studenti un luogo di
immigrazione di giovani i giovani che
vengono a studiare appunto delle volte
si fermano anche per lavorare anche se
negli ultimi anni forse abbiamo perso un
po di sbocchi al lavoro ma l'idea il mio
di massima e che torino sia una città
abbastanza accogliente per i giovani ed
è tutto sommato vero
l'altra caratteristica che a questo
posto e forse di essere un laboratorio
un laboratorio da cui magari poi si
scappa per andare a esercitare da altre
parti
ma l'anima della città l'anima da
laboratorio
tutto sommato c'era e c'è e questo ci ha
ispirato perché l'idea che abbiamo avuto
era quella di creare un laboratorio un
piccolo laboratorio sulla comunicazione
in cui invitare un'intera generazione
che è la generazione dei ragazzi di oggi
che tutto sommato sono appassionati di
comunicazione di default di nascita sono
fotografi registi blogger social media
che poi si chiamano manager nel futuro
ma insomma i ragazzi nascono dovendo
confrontarsi con un sacco di talenti
noi abbiamo pensato che si potessero
mettere insieme e vedere se insieme ne
nasceva qualche cosa oltre alla nostra
radice da laboratorio da città
laboratorio
abbiamo cercato ispirazione altrove e
come diceva woody allen
se devi cercare ispirazione cerca la un
po alta così abbiamo messo insieme la e
bottega d arte e mestiere del
rinascimento è un po di andy warhol che
non sta mai male ma soprattutto che
aveva avuto un'idea di una factory tutto
sommato in tempi più recenti rispetto al
rinascimento
e allora abbiamo messo insieme l'idea di
laboratorio
l'idea di andy warhol l'idea delle arti
e mestieri ne è nato un piccolo spazio
dove ogni anno una ventina di ragazzi
attraverso un concorso vengono
selezionati e vengono assunti per un
anno lavorano a torino vengono da tutte
le parti d'italia stanno con noi un anno
e poi ripartono
ma la cosa interessante per noi e forse
anche un po per chi mi sta ascoltando in
questo momento sono tutto sommato i
risultati dopo perché il 90 per cento
più o meno dei ragazzi che è passato da
noi è diventato se stesso o meglio ha
iniziato una carriera di lavoro facendo
il proprio lavoro e questo secondo noi è
il risultato più grande ma come diceva
prima matteo introducendo mi il mio
intervento a una domanda iniziale e se
questa esperienza per caso
è riproducibile e una domanda alla quale
io non ho una risposta se non un
indicazione e tutto sommato una speranza
perché io sono convinto che
l'innovazione in questi anni e ne
parliamo tantissimo passi attraverso la
tecnologia passi attraverso il digitale
passi attraverso la ricerca ma sono
convinto che passi attraverso anche un
modo diverso di intendere il lavoro e se
per caso qualche grande azienda avesse
voglia di imitarci e di assumere dieci
quindici ragazze di tenerli dentro per
un anno dandogli quel confine temporale
ricordandogli che dopo un anno se ne
andranno in modo da non dargli il tempo
di prendere le abitudini di diventare
vittime di direttori generali di
amministratori delegati o quantomeno
dall'atmosfera generale che regna nelle
aziende e di essere provocatori e
anarchici e aver voglia di inseguire i
propri sogni
e i sogni delle aziende di dare delle
indicazioni oneste ebbene io credo che
se qualche azienda assumesse un gruppo
di ragazzi così se ne gioverebbe
moltissimo i ragazzi potrebbero mettere
nel proprio curriculum
il nome di grandi imprese e le imprese
potrebbero mettere nella propria storia
la libertà di pensiero che spesso manca
grazie
[Applauso]